through my journey i figured out the one
piece i was missing i thought it was
cars i thought it was women i thought it
was i thought it was my i thought was
everything the one piece i was missing
was me having the courage to face myself
and once you do that on a daily basis
it's not about the running
work people's going to be just about
working out where i got my work ethic
from
was the hours i had to spend learning
this
when you sit down and you're not smart
and you have a disability yeah
and you still want to be in the top of
your class i didn't want to get by
when i realized that i can learn through
hard work
and i can beat the valedictorian in
school but i got put in 10 hours more a
day than he does you know what kind of
strength comes from that
when you're sitting down that guy that
that valedictorian study for an hour and
you know i caught you
i caught you and i am dumb but i have
the work ethic to catch you that's where
david gaga's got really invented yeah
was at a kitchen table
with 20 spiral notebooks that were empty
and then three months later yeah they
were full
and when you can go through that i still
have them in my storage unit you're
going through these spiral notebooks of
your life
and you realize this is how i learned
this is unbelievable there's no miles
it's not about the miles it's that
having a discipline every day they say
for me to learn this one math problem
it's gonna take me 10 hours
and that's where it and you realize
through hard work
you can do you can outwork anybody no
matter how badass they are
but that's the part people don't want to
dive into
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how to
master the art of self-discipline
rule number two embrace discomfort with
thomas frank find ways to embrace
discomfort and embrace the resistance
you feel towards doing something that
takes hard work or that's unpleasant
just like going to an actual gym and
lifting weights makes you better at
lifting weights in the future and able
to lift more weight the next time you go
in every time you embrace discomfort you
are essentially doing a rep of the
exercise that is self-discipline because
it is a skill that can be learned it is
a muscle that can be built over time
this is why i'm such a proponent of
taking cold showers because a cold
shower is something that most people
don't want to do it's not very
comfortable standing underneath that
stream of ice cold water and that's the
point every morning that you get into
the shower and you choose to turn that
handle to cold instead of hot you are
embracing discomfort you're leaning into
the resistance and that makes you better
at doing so in the future regardless of
what the task is so as you go through
your daily life find ways to embrace
discomfort it could be cold showers it
could be signing up for a 6 a.m rotc
fitness class it could be taking the
stairs instead of the elevator basically
whatever your brain throws up that i
don't feel like an excuse that is an
opportunity to build that
self-discipline muscle and you should
take it rule number three delegate more
with brendon burchard you want to be
more disciplined
you're going to have to delegate more
you want to be more disciplined to what
really matters for you you're going to
ask for assistance for help you're gonna
have to build the team you have to
socially engage people to support
your focus
it's just real like every writer i know
who's become a major writer
has assistance
meaning they get some of their their
spouse their partner
their agent a personal assistant
somebody is helping with a part of their
life so they can focus on that thing
right it's hard to be a disciplined
writer if you're doing everything under
the sun you need time to be able to
write which means there's some things
you can't handle under by yourself
and you're going to delegate that and if
you're like well brendan i don't have
anyone to delegate to then i'm like then
stop saying yes to everything under the
sun
stop putting more and more on your plate
when you can't handle what you already
got babe we got to go no no no
if i want to be disciplined
i got to choose a few things
say no to the rest
delegate the rest
and do what is here
you don't lack discipline you're taking
on too much
you don't lack discipline you're taking
on too much
or you don't have a schedule or you
don't know your outcome
outcome schedule delegation and last
thing is
what i think this is really a critical
thing for us in
aliveness and fulfillment and connection
in our lives
often we don't have discipline because
we've set up no reward and reflection in
our life
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four focus on the most
important goal with brian tracy all
successful men and women are highly
disciplined in the important work that
they do
all unsuccessful men and women are
undisciplined and unable to control
their behaviors and their appetites
and when you develop the same levels of
high personal discipline possessed by
the most goal oriented successful people
in our society you will very soon begin
to achieve the same results that they do
it's no miracle
all great success in life is preceded by
long sustained periods of focused effort
on a single goal the most important goal
with the determination to stay with it
until it is complete
throughout history we find that every
man or woman who achieves anything
lasting and worthwhile had engaged in
long often unappreciated hours
weeks months and even years of
concentrated discipline work in a
particular direction
fortunately the quality of
self-discipline is something that you
can learn by continuous practice
over and over until you master it
once you've mastered the ability to
delay gratification the ability to
discipline yourself to keep your
attention focused on the most important
task in front of you there is virtually
no goal that you cannot accomplish and
no tasks that you cannot complete i have
studied successful men and women for
more than 40 years and in the simplest
of terms successful men and women are
those who work almost all the time on
high value tasks
unsuccessful men and women are those who
waste their time by wasting the minutes
and hours of each day on low value
activities
you see there is a crowding out
principle in time and personal
management
it simply says that if you spend all of
your time on highly productive tasks by
the end of the day you will have crowded
out
all the unproductive activities that
might have distracted you from your real
work and from what's really important
on the other hand if you spend your time
on low value activities the reverse
happens those low value activities will
crowd out the time that you need to
complete the task that can make all the
difference in your life
and the key to this attitude toward time
and personal management is always
self-discipline
there are several disciplines that you
need to develop if you want to achieve
your full potential
the first of these is the discipline of
goals
this means that you sit down with a pad
of paper a pen
and ample time to think
you think through and then make a
written list of all the things that you
want to accomplish in the next one two
three four and five years
you organize the list into the various
areas of your life your career your
money your family your health and the
other parts that are important to you
interestingly enough
if you can be clear about your goals and
write them down there's nothing that can
stop you from achieving them
but if you're not clear
that means that you haven't written them
down there's nothing that can help you
you set priorities among your goals and
rewrite your lists so that your most
important goals are at the top
you then take a separate sheet of paper
and you make a list of all the things
that you can think of doing right now
to move you toward the attainment of
your most important goals rule number
five just do it with john maxwell i've
never met a person who was not
successful that didn't have a great
amount of self-discipline within their
life
self-discipline and being able to
perform and being able to keep your life
on schedule and being able to keep
commitments and promises and meet
deadlines is essential to success
none of us
none of us can afford to have a life
that is controlled by someone else or a
life that is basically controlled by our
emotions
i learned many years ago that there are
two kinds of people there's the type of
person who says i'm gonna wait till i
feel like it before i do it and then
there's a person who says i've got to do
it so that i feel like it
one will never get anything done because
they're still waiting to feel the moment
to move and the other person says no i
need to move and then i will begin to
feel the moment sonja self-discipline
is essential in your life and in my life
if we're going to get things done
so i have a challenge for every one of
you this weekend the challenge is simple
as you go through your weekend and
sometimes it's kind of a hopefully an
easier time of your week
ask yourself
am i practicing self-discipline in my
life
am i doing the things that i should do
because i need to do them or am i kind
of waiting to feel the moment and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus clips is be relentless
with jared glant you have to be
relentless
you have to be completely not
unreasonable no excuses this is the only
way it's going to be especially when you
don't want to do it i mean that's the
that's the differentiator between the
average and the successful is doing the
hardest thing you could possibly think
of even when you don't want to do it
and so like when you're when you're
trying to figure out like let's just
take making phone calls for example uh
let's say you at the end of this what
you should do is you should write out a
list of everything that you want to be
more disciplined with right i gave you a
list of eight things there attitude diet
and exercise uh the friends you keep
your environment the choices that you
make the actions that you take your
personal development your thoughts the
things you say uh and then you're
dressed in attire there's a list of
eight you know that those are just eight
that i thought of the your list of eight
could be totally different right but
pick those those top five top ten things
that you know you need to be more
disciplined in
okay don't don't don't tackle the whole
list at the same time okay you might be
able to to handle that i can't like for
me it it doesn't work right so what i
had to do is i got to go after each one
of these until the skill is set right so
i'm going to go after my attitude hey
what can i do to be had to have a better
attitude on a daily basis man dude i
want to think about my goals i want to
have signs up around me be positive
success is your duty i had on my window
where i used to make uh in in our la
office uh we had a window that
overlooked the hollywood hills and on
the window i wrote don't be a little
[ __ ] right every single day man i
didn't want to be a [ __ ] i didn't want
to [ __ ] out on the call i didn't want
to [ __ ] out with the customer i wanted
to ask the hard question so i had that
right in front of me i wanted to be more
aware so that i could have more control
over it right diet and exercise right
maybe that's the next thing okay so you
get the attitude locked in you you
you've been you've been jamming on the
attitude thing for two three four weeks
okay and then you move into diet
now if you don't work out the first time
you try to go to exercise tell me it
didn't it's not like oh man this is hard
and then you get sore and you're like
man the next morning comes you're
rolling around in bed the alarm going
off you ain't even step foot out of the
bed and it already hurts right
dude you got to be disciplined to throw
one foot out the next foot out and get
your ass up out of bed
right and then you got to do it the next
day and the next day and after two or
three weeks tell me it ain't easier you
start waking up before the alarm goes
off right because you've built that
discipline the consistency is built
discipline for you
okay
so i mean like look at the end of the
day you got to figure out what those
things are for you that you need to be
more disciplined in but i can guarantee
you that discipline
in your life
will have a large large effect on how
successful you end up becoming
and it's not in the things may change
the list may change that's why it's it's
so important to get this process in now
and this really is a process it's
something that you can look at and it's
something that you can implement with
where you're at right now
so so so that you know it at 26 years
old i've got one set of things i need to
be more disciplined with right
uh you know it
it was being disciplined maybe not
smoking weed you know before i that was
you know i smoked a lot of weed you know
i had to be disciplined to get off of it
i had to stop one day at a time first
day hey done with this second day not
going back third day it's in the rear
view mirror fourth day fifth day sixth
day it's gone
i built the muscle where it wasn't an
issue
you know 30 okay hey now what can i do
to go from from 250 to 500 k a year what
can i do what can i do every day where
do i need to be thinking right when
you're when you're 35 it may change when
you're 40 it may change when you're 50
it may change but when i look at a guy
like grant right who's extremely
successful dude he's already got all the
discipline built in for all the things
that we're trying to do right now
right
and now he's disciplined for even bigger
goals how do i get to a billion in real
estate i want to be a billionaire how do
i get there
so look this discipline thing will carry
it will carry with you you'll carry it
your entire life that's why it's so
important to get it built in now
tip number one is create a morning
routine you have to start off right so
many times it happens with entrepreneurs
and it happened to me so many multiple
times you get inspired randomly i would
get inspired randomly i would meet
somebody for a coffee and we'd be
bubbling ideas and i'd get so inspired
and go home and work or listen to a a
youtube video or read a book or
something it would just fire me up and
i'd be working like crazy and then the
next day i would wake up and like poof
it's like it's gone i'm starting over
from scratch i felt like i start over
from scratch and i still do i feel like
i start from scratch every single day
the baseline becomes maybe a little bit
higher
over time but i'm still starting off
from scratch i don't wake up energized
passionate ready to go attack the day
you know that's not me at least maybe
that's you maybe that's some people if
that's you you're probably not watching
this video but i think most people wake
up starting from scratch i think we put
on this entrepreneur mask and be like
yeah i'm hosting hard i'm grinding but
we wake up and we're not we're not
grinding we're not we're not super
motivated it doesn't mean we hate our
life but we know we could be working
harder i think you need a daily reset
and it's figuring out what is the one
thing that gets you inspired that gets
you passionate that gets you motivated
that gets you the oomph right it's like
i want to go do something today you've
all felt that feeling before i know what
it is for me for me a lot of times it's
it's the videos it's watching
successful people having success like
that's that's what i want to do and
seeing it on a regular basis makes me
want to do it so i made the channel
selfishly for myself too like the top 10
and the meant to me all those it's for
me i want to see it i want to get
motivated i want to be inspired i want
to learn knowledge yes but just seeing
people doing great things makes me want
to do great things so that's what helps
me so so start your day with it that's
why i did the espresso series like start
your day with a shot of espresso to get
you going but if that's not your thing
it's cool like you don't have to watch
my channel i get it
read a book
meet with a friend you know listen to a
podcast whatever the thing is there's no
judgment you know like
playing with your ring gets you excited
or waxing your eyebrows or whatever it
is like it doesn't matter whatever the
thing is
that gets you like raw this day is going
to be great
do that every day start your day with it
because if you start your day off
on the wrong foot or you start your day
off just falling into your schedule
you may not be inspired the whole day or
you may randomly come across something
at four o'clock that day and then that's
what gets you all motivated but you've
lost from when you wake up to four
o'clock right there's a lot of time in
there that could have been way more
productive focusing on important things
and so find the thing that gets you
motivated that gets you energized and
start your day with it every single day
[Music]
tip number two is create a regular
schedule i think it's way easier to be
disciplined when you have a schedule
that you are following one of the
hardest things i think for entrepreneurs
is
we have to balance this thing if we want
creative freedom we want creative
expression we want to be able to do what
we want to do but also we need to have
some kind of routine some kind of
discipline because left to our own means
we may not wake up and do anything on
that day or at least anything of
substance or values it's easy to get
distracted by other things and it's not
furthering our goals and so what i find
really helps for me is i create a
regular schedule and every day i kind of
know what i'm doing and i chunk my time
some mondays are one thing and cheese is
another thing and wednesday's another
thing and so on for the rest of the week
and when i wake up on a monday morning
i don't have to think about what i'm
doing today it's already there it's on
my list i have my tasks i know what i'm
doing monday i start with a great you
know morning ritual and then i'm into my
day right
and i think that helps most of the time
i think on the rare occasion that you
feel
inspired by something else like i wake
up and i want to really want to go off
and do that
i'll often go out and do that and cancel
everything else that i was working on
for that day because chances are what i
create in that moment is going to be
gold like when you're in the flow and
you're really feeling something what's
going to come out of that is going to be
golden the challenge is you're not in
the flow every day at least me i'm not
in flow every day i don't wake up in
flow i'm just like a whole day of flow
and i'm ready to go that's not me it's
not you great ignore this point but most
people don't wake up and just flow the
whole day and so i have the routine for
when you know most of my days and then
when i'm in flow i go and follow that
passion
at the same time when i feel like my
something's missing or i feel like i
want to add something else to my
schedule it means something else has to
be pulled out and so whenever i feel
like the work that i'm doing in my
calendar is not matching up to what i
want to do i have a vision i have dreams
i have other interests i want to pursue
then i start to change my schedule so
the schedule is what i live by it's what
i wake up and do on most days and if i
know it's in my schedule it's going to
get done
super important because left my own
devices i would still be productive but
nowhere near as productive nowhere near
as disciplined and so knowing what
you're going to do when you wake up and
not have to make choices on the side
every single time makes life a lot
easier
[Music]
tip number three is track your progress
there's a famous expression that what
gets measured gets done or gets
accomplished
when you are tracking what you're doing
you're more likely to pay attention to
it and want to fix it and so you know if
your goal is to lose weight if you're
tracking your weight every day and
you're tracking your calories every day
you're much more likely to lose weight
you know if your goal is to call 10
customers a day or reach out to 10
people a day or you know make a youtube
video every week if you are tracking it
then you're more likely to follow
through on it just like when you're
making goals the more specific you are
the more likely you're going to hit it
if your goal is to just lose weight then
you're unlikely to do it but if your
goal is to lose 10 pounds or 20 pounds
or your goal is to hit you know 50 000
in more revenue or whatever your goal is
you're more likely to hit it because
you're being specific and so if you're
tracking it on a daily basis or a weekly
basis then you want to hit those numbers
you know when i'm working out with my
personal trainer you know he gives me
goals that i need to hit you know i need
to
hit 900 calories a week in cardio as an
example right now so i have to do 45
minutes in two chunks 45 minutes and 45
minutes on the
on the machine and i'm usually on social
media you guys can check me out there
when i'm answering your questions
would i do 45 minutes without him
maybe maybe i do 15 minutes maybe yeah
okay i did some cardio right but if
you're tracking it and you know what's
happening and you make a spreadsheet or
use a checklist or whatever it is how
you want to track don't get caught up in
the tools the tools don't matter it
could be a piece of paper and a pen when
you're checking something off and you
know you've got it done you're much more
likely to follow through what gets
tracked gets done so anything you want
to stay disciplined on have some kind of
tracking system in place
email or evernote or a crm or a calendar
anything something just so that you're
tracking it consistently
[Music]
tip number four is commit to somebody
else when you commit to somebody else
you're much more likely to follow
through the reason is we will let other
people down less than we'll let
ourselves down
it's easy to let ourselves down how many
times do we say i'm gonna do something
but then you don't do it you're letting
yourself down right constantly even for
you guys who snooze we didn't talk about
that yet it's not on my list but let's
go here now don't snooze stop hitting
the snooze button the thing that happens
when you hit the snooze button is i'm
going to wake up at 8am or i'm going to
wake up at 7am and the first thing you
do
is say that goal is not important to me
that's not going to happen the first
thing you do every morning if you hit
the snooze button is let yourself down
that's how you start your day and if you
hit the snooze button five times you
start your day every day by letting
yourself down five times
how well do you think that bows for you
to have a great day
stop hitting the snooze button you're
snoozing you're snoozing on everything
you're snoozing on your dreams you're
snoozing on your life stop it get up
back to the story so when you commit to
somebody else you're more likely to
follow through
i do this in my workout as an example
you know i commit to my wife nina and
sean a personal trainer that on mondays
and wednesdays we're going to work out
i'm there at five o'clock and we work
out if i'm feeling tired if i'm feeling
you know stressed out lots of work it's
easy to say you know what i'm not going
to do that that's not important but
because they're going to be there i'm
going to be there right when i come in
on mondays to work at toronto dance also
here i work with alex and i work with
lily and they're going to be here and
they're expecting me to be here we have
a meeting set and i have to go over
stuff with them i have to show up i'm
not going to let them down so whatever
goal you have whatever you want to stay
more disciplined with
try to line up somebody to be with try
to line up a meeting try to line up a
schedule try to line up something with
somebody else because if you commit to
them you're more likely to follow
through
tip number five is have big whys and
little wise it's really important to
have a big why to feel like what you're
doing is inspiring is motivating there's
a reason for you to get up and do work
if you feel like the work you're doing
is not important
you're not going to stay disciplined on
it if you feel like the work you're
doing is just pushing paper and just
filling out forms and grunt work and
administrative work it's something you
don't care about you're not going to
work hard if you feel your work is
meaningless you don't want to work hard
on that it's really hard to stay
disciplined on it and so having a big
why to know that the work that you're
doing matters means something to people
you're working towards building a better
life for yourself whether you're
thinking about yourself and in that
ideal life you're trying to build
whether you think about your family your
community or the customers you're
serving having a big why helps you stay
motivated so for me i want to help a
billion entrepreneurs that's a big scary
ambitious goal right can i can i do it
is it possible
the work i do has meaning
right i'm making these videos trying to
extend that goal it's not just oh i
gotta film more videos as soon as i get
to that point i'm done on youtube if i
dread the thought of coming in and
making videos or if it's just okay like
yeah yeah whatever gotta go make some
videos i'm done i have to move on to
something else you have to do meaningful
work and so thinking about what your big
goal is what your big vision is the
change you want to make and looking at
that on a regular basis keeping that in
mind and seeing how your work
ties into you accomplishing that big
goal is really important that's your big
why at the same time you need to have
your little why's because the big why
takes a long time the big why is a
lifetime goal right or or a year goal or
five year like it's it's out there it's
not going to happen today it's not going
to happen tomorrow and so thinking long
term sometimes can be very motivating
but sometimes it can also
bring you down sometimes it can also
make you feel depressed like i'm never
going to hit that who am i to hit that
big goal i can't go out and do these big
things and so it doesn't always serve
you to the best that it can
and so that's why the little y's are
really important and the little y's are
the day-to-day little meanings that you
have in your business so for me as an
example the big why is helping a billion
entrepreneurs the little why are the
comments that you guys leave the little
wise logging in every day and seeing
that
you know johnny really loved my video
and it made a big impact like your
comments mean a lot to me i look at them
every day
it inspires me and inspires my team and
and we know that
yes we're helping millions of people
right we have millions of views every
month happening on the channel we've had
over 100 million views on the channel
it's number it's it's hard to even
imagine 100 million people watching
these videos but then to know that this
one person
liked it and appreciated it and talked
about the impact that it had those
day-to-day interactions are really
important when i was first getting
started up in this business of helping
entrepreneurs i would find this huge
spike of enjoyment when i did i did
speaking engagements and i would speak
and just feel so great but it may be two
weeks until my next speaking gig
and then in between i felt down like i
didn't have anything like what i'm not
getting any feedback i don't know that
my work is meaningful or contributing
and so i would make a powerpoint file
that i would watch every morning and in
it i would include some of the feedback
from the people who were in my sessions
some of the complimentary things that
people had to say for me to feel like
yeah like the work i do is meaningful it
matters and it's the little why it's not
solving a big problem it's helping one
person with one thing they had in their
business so i think that combination
feeling like you're doing something
important on a big scale and also
knowing that the work you do today is
touching one person's life and having an
impact
it's easier much easier to stay
disciplined and on task
[Music]
tip number six is have a designated
workplace this is really important for
entrepreneurs who are working from home
it can be hard
when you have all the comforts of your
home to float in between and try to work
from the kitchen and work from the couch
and work from your bedroom or wherever
it is that you work it can be hard to
stay on task it's easy to get distracted
by oh what's in the fridge oh what's on
tv oh who's that calling oh the dog
needs to be walked or all the little
tasks that kind of come up and get you
distracted if you have an easy time
staying focused then it doesn't matter
right it doesn't matter at all you're
fine but you're not watching this video
because you have a hard time staying
disciplined you want some tips and so
i would suggest having designated place
to work and also designated time so that
you know
from 9 a.m to 1 p.m you're gonna work at
this place and maybe that's outside the
home it could be leaving it could be
going to a coffee shop or going to a
library or going to a place of business
somewhere that you're going to go out
there and work
or it could be designated spot and you
know you have a home office in the
garage that you're setting up and when
you're there you work and when you're
not there then you don't work and i
think that makes it easier for people to
have a hard time staying disciplined you
create a routine that allows you to stay
disciplined so an example when
alex and lily both started working for
me and were i'm helping mentor and coach
them to become entrepreneurs
i give them options like you can either
work from home
you can either work with me you can work
from tds you can work from my place you
can follow me around you can whatever
you want to do whatever works best for
your schedule whatever works best for
your personality style and if they want
to be around me all the time and that
helps kind of keep consistency and like
show up here at nine o'clock great if
they want to work from home or work from
a coffee shop great but creating a
schedule helps especially if you're not
the disciplined kind of person to know
that you know monday tuesday wednesday
thursday friday saturdays whenever
whatever days you're working put it in i
have a designated place that when i'm
going here i'm focused i'm shutting off
all those distractions and i'm working
[Music]
and tip number seven is do something you
love and this is a tip that comes up
most often when i look at famous
entrepreneurs and how they achieve
success they did something that they
loved if you are forcing yourself to do
something that you don't love you can
only do it for so long before you're
going to quit and want to give up and
want to move on to something else
because you don't love it
you know not every day is amazing as an
entrepreneur but you have to actually
enjoy doing the work where if you sit
down and you're doing the work you you
don't see it as much as being
disciplined to have to do it because you
actually enjoy doing it and so a lot of
people just set these big goals for
themselves and they'll do whatever it
takes to go and get there but if they
don't actually enjoy the process of
doing it they're never going to actually
go and achieve those goals
much more important is that the work
that you're doing is something that you
are passionate about there has to be
something in your business that you can
get lost in there has to be if
everything is just work to you you're
not going to make it like quit now and
go do something else that you can get
lost in not every piece of your business
you're going to be able to get lost in
especially at the beginning because
you're doing everything you may not get
lost in the accounting of your business
maybe you love accounting and that's
great
be an accountant but otherwise a lot of
people don't want to do the account
inside or don't want to care about their
taxes and all that kind of stuff it has
to get done but there has to be
something in your business that you can
get lost in and forget what time it is
and the more you're doing that kind of
work
the more you're going to be able to not
just stay disciplined but achieve your
big goals and as soon as possible i'd be
looking at how can i build a team to be
able to take away some of the things
that i don't like that i keep getting
you know drawn in by or keep
procrastinating
and give that to somebody else so i can
focus on what i can be great at i always
wanted to win the world cup
that was the reason i started and as the
time went by
i started enjoying cricket and i started
realizing the challenges of cricket
and my coach was instrumental and along
with my brother
to to my
elder brother ajit
to make me realize
the the importance of
leading a disciplined life a focused
life
and
to to to
to make me push harder
they found reasons
and and even
towards the end of my career i followed
that formula
if i scored runs
let the rest of the world talk about it
i think about the next game and that
right from my school days became an
unwritten formula unwritten law at home
that we don't talk about last game
we talk about next game
and however many runs i scored
i wanted to go out and score more than
that
so if i didn't score
i would have a restless night if i
scored runs
i would still have a restless night
thinking that how am i going to score
more and that's how it all happened i
mean i
i normally don't discuss numbers but
this is something that i must
share with all of you
i towards the end of my
school cricket career i already started
playing first class cricket
and
the last season i can proudly say that i
averaged
1025 because i only got out once in the
whole season
my brother and my coach was instrumental
in that because
every time i scored drunks
none of them said well played to me and
that's why in my farewell speech
i said i said to my coach that at least
now you can take a chance by saying well
done
there is there are no no more matches in
my career but
something that that i lived for was
appreciation from my coach and my
brother which never happened i mean and
that was something which
you know sort of kept me giving uh
giving my best all the time in 2009 um
when the uh the mixtape
and and there was a period where i i
think around that time you were kind of
like you know is this something that's
going to work for me or not
um
what is it that got you through how did
you how did you work through that
yeah i it's tough to say exactly what i
think it was hard work it was it was
discipline it was knowing that if this
doesn't work out then i will have to get
a nine to five
and
i don't want to do
i really don't want to do that
and it was it was working with ryan and
putting everything into the music and
you know for i mean leading up to that
point i think that
you have to look at my track record i
had always wanted to get sober i could
never get sober i was ner i couldn't
make music while i was under the
influence of drugs or alcohol finally
got sober in 2008 got out of rehab and
was like all right this is it i've
wasted years of my life
and if this is going to work
it has to work now
there's no alternative and i met
somebody that
had the same dedication as me
that
put everything into the music everything
into the craft and didn't go out
and didn't really have
many friends
just kidding just kidding
we only hang out with each other
no but somebody that wasn't gonna you
know be like
you know i was up until that point i was
making music with people that were
constantly putting their priorities into
getting cooler people right getting no
not at all yeah getting um
getting loaded or chasing women or
whatever and that's what i did for a
long time and it didn't it led me to
being broken in rehab and moving back
into my parents house
which is awesome but um
i i wanted a career and and ryan was
somebody that had this the same
discipline yeah and and sacrificed
everything
in high school i must have been
maybe 16 or 17 years old
and
i went rock climbing in el dorado canyon
where i near where i grew up in boulder
i was i've been climbing about three or
four years and i went to do a climb
called t2
at the time t2 was a relatively
difficult climb
and i went at it with a a kind of an
arrogant lack of preparation and i
hadn't prepared for being able to do
certain kinds of finger cracks i figure
i'll i'll figure it out when i get there
and i also didn't pause this i think
about boldness and discipline i didn't
pause to really double smack double
check all my systems okay
so i'm on the fourth pitch
i'm about 400 feet above the ground
i'm going across this slanting crack
system that i'd had trouble that i
started have trouble with my forearms
started to engorge with blood and lactic
acid which means at some point even if
you're on a big hole your hands are
going to melt off okay
and i'm about to fall
i'm 400 a feet above the ground
but it should be okay because there's
protection
i'm tied into the rope i may take a fall
but i'll get caught
for some reason and to this day i still
don't know why
my brain triggered
that i should look at my knot
and i looked down at my knot
my knot had come untied
i had made the mistake of never really
thinking about the best knot for certain
types of situations and i tied him with
what's a bowline now the advantage of a
bowline is it's easy to untie if you
right the disadvantage of a bolden is
it's easy to untie
it had come untied as i kept moving
across
and it is just hanging in my harness
i'm seconds away from falling only now i
will die
i will die
if i fall off
my forearms are melting
and the knot had come untied and so i
called down to my partner i said why not
come on time what's he going to do he
can't do anything he'll just watch me
fall to my death
and i there was an old fixed piton
in the rock that we put there from the
first descent an old soft iron piton and
i looked at it and i probably had 15 20
seconds before my hands would unwrap if
that maybe 10.
i took a runner and i clipped it into
the piton
i clipped the piton into my heart that
runner into my harness and just went
please hold
and i let go
and it helped okay
i put in a backup
i grabbed the knot be tied it went to
the ledge didn't convulsion i was very
calm at that moment i got to the ledge i
went into convulsive shaking i was sick
to my stomach for days because of the
the whatever happens chemically
what i learned from that is two things
the first is that when you're in an
unforgiving world when gravity is
unforgiving it doesn't care
it never takes a day off ever
and if you make one mistake it can kill
you
if it's the wrong kind of mistake and
what i learned is that sense of yeah i
want to do adventurous things i want to
climb rocks i want to be in yosemite i
want to do things that get my adrenaline
going
i but i need the discipline to always do
all the right preparation to always
think about the right knots to always be
cross checking my systems so that i can
do those bold things and stay alive in
an unforgiving environment and as you
and i spoke about earlier today i think
that's the rest of i think we're all
heading into an unforgiving environment
where we're going to have to be both
bold and disciplined
the second thing i learned what if that
piton had not been there
we might not be here together
it was just by chance
that that piton was right there
and what you realize when you rewind the
tape of your own life is that there are
these crucial moments
where if the luck had gone the other way
you might have gotten killed
and so what you have to do is to always
be ex putting those extra disciplines in
place
because i was lucky to live
and what i took from that is i never
want to have to be lucky
to live again
i want to live because of my discipline
not because of my luck
self-discipline carried wilbur and
orville wright through a multitude of
failures
and enabled them finally to give the
world its first practical airplane an
achievement which has made the world
smaller and
changed the entire trend of civilization
self-discipline helped helen keller to
triumph over deafness blindness and
dumbness a combination of afflictions
such as most people
never experience
self-discipline help me to carry on
through years of heartache
discouragement and defeat
and give the world the first practical
philosophy of success
based on the know-how
gained by hundreds of men and women
who spent a lifetime by the trial and
error method
in discovery of the principles which
lead to personal success
self-discipline is among the top-ranking
features of all the great religions
including of course the christian faith
and there are some people who believe
that our major purpose on earth is that
of developing wisdom
through struggle and self-discipline
one thing is certain
no one ever becomes very wise without
the aid of self-discipline
and no one ever finds peace of mind
and happiness without the strict
exercise of self-discipline
self-discipline is the only means of
transmuting sorrow
into faith
it is the only means by which we may
transmute hatred of others into the
milder emotion of
sympathy for them it is the only means
by which we may reveal and
profit by the seed of an equivalent
benefit which comes with every adversity
and every defeat
it is the only means by which we may
shut out of our minds the deadly effects
of past experiences of suffering and
unpleasantness
and it is the means by which we may
discover that other self
we carry around with us that self which
has great capacity for belief
and does not become influenced by
failure and defeat
self-discipline can give us freedom from
the fear of death the most difficult to
master of all of our fears
it can free us from the disease of
hypochondria the fear of imaginary
illness with which so many people suffer
and sometimes die
self-discipline is the means by which we
may think our own thoughts
live our own lives as we wish to live
them and remain forever free from the
evils of fears and limitations which we
have inherited from the dark ages before
the dawn of civilization
oftentimes people will come to me for
advice on fitness on building their
businesses and their relationships
whatever the case may be and often
the place that they're dropping the ball
is in
bad habits or not building productive
habits
because it's very difficult to just get
up and change your life just change the
way you do things people like to say
that all the time hey just stop doing
this or start doing that they like to
give advice but the the underlying
factor is that our friend our individual
whoever is asking the question is not
disciplined enough to actually put that
thing in action get that thing done so
the thing that i have always told my
students and my clients is to start with
a small win begin with something small
so for example if you want to lose
weight i often tell people just start
walking every single morning don't worry
about counting calories don't worry
about complex workout ideas don't worry
about anything that anyone is selling
you just get up and walk every morning
right now it's not the walking that's
actually going to make that person
successful now it will add to your
success because getting up and walking
fresh air and exercise is going to
support you and losing weight but we all
know that there's far more
factors
to consider but what it will do is
create the virtue of discipline
commitment right commitment and
discipline sort of go together
and the fact that that small win
associated with getting up every single
morning
is under your belt you're going to feel
the courage the confidence and you'll
have the ability to begin adding other
things
to your ability to grow stronger so now
that you know it's been 60 days 90 days
and it's like you got that pattern down
pat you get up every morning you just
walk that's it you don't think about it
it's become a habit you now can use that
tool of creating habits and instilling
discipline with the next one which
should be a little bit more advanced
perhaps only drink water with
your meals don't drink any soda don't
drink any juice just drink water that's
the next one
and then the next one becomes more
complex and the next one becomes more
complex now it might seem like this is
tedious and slow but i guarantee you
that after 90 days of tiny winds
and the revamping of your character you
will be the type of person that can get
anything done at any time and the long
time perspective is going to be a
successful one for you start small have
big
wins with these little things and then
use that new version of yourself that
new character tool to attack bigger and
more advanced
things until you reach your goal i keep
getting asked this type of question how
do i get disciplined or how do i want
discipline or how do i maintain
discipline
and the answer it's it's a simple answer
but obviously it's
not easy
and there's all kinds of little
tricks and methods that people talk
about
and
you know they have
some merit you know maybe they do work
these these things you know do the
little things people say and wake up
early i say that and write things down
and take cold showers
and
tell everyone what you're going to do
so broadcast it
and make promises
or or make bets
with with your friends
of something that you don't want to lose
and those things those ideas
they're they're cool i'm sure they're
going to have some impact and if they
work for you
that's that's awesome
but but the fact of the matter is
that the reason discipline is hard to
maintain is because it is hard to
maintain
that's what makes discipline hard it's
hard
and
if you hear me claim
that
discipline is easy for me
then
straight up that's just my ego talking
that's what that is because
i'm
unfortunately
just as human as everyone else and it is
work to maintain the discipline that's
what it is work
holding the line
maintaining the standard
giving no slack none that's the
discipline
[Music]
that's the discipline and it is hard
and if there's one thing i would say
that does
make it easier
[Music]
it's to
envision what it feels like when you're
done
what it
feels like
after you've worked out or you've held
the line on your food intake or you've
pushed through some
monotonous
project
that you have to do and all those things
when they're done they feel good
and
contrary to that
envision what you will feel like later
when you let the discipline slack
you know the feeling
feeling weak
and defeated and you know that you're
falling behind
so get to know those
two different types of feelings and ask
yourself
which one you want to feel in 10 minutes
[Music]
or
in a half an hour
when
when the thing is done when the
discipline has been implemented
remember what that feels like and then
remember that those
minutes and those hours they turn into
weeks and months and years and holding
the line in those critical minutes will
put you in an infinitely better place
physically and mentally if you maintain
the discipline
so work through the weakness fight
through the temptation hold the line
hold the line maintain the discipline it
is not easy
but it is worth it
[Music]
because
yes
because discipline
equals
freedom remove temptation
you must remove temptations
if you are going to have self-discipline
i'm trying to say
if you are trying to lose weight if you
are trying to get better if you are
trying to do things in a good good way
you have to remove the temptations me i
had a problem with pornography years ago
and now it's one of those things that i
had to eliminate
temptations i had to eliminate things
that i felt would would trigger me and
get me back going on the wrong path and
it's really really subtle one of the
things is by examining
what the way you think and how you act
in a given situation um i find that
there were times like friday night is
when i felt like that was the time to
view pornography you know why because i
remember
everyone going out on friday and feeling
real sexy and feeling like woo and women
and this and dancing and partying and
all that and then i would i would do it
i'd say no i'm not gonna do that i'm a
good boy but i'm gonna stay home and i'm
gonna watch porn which was a horrible
horrible habit so friday night i know
when those feelings are coming and when
that i get sensitive and i feel like um
you know this might be the time to click
on something you know what i mean and i
know it and i headed off at the past you
just make sure that you know where you
are and you avoid those temptations the
same thing with eating if you know you
have a problem with donuts
do not go to the donut shop to get your
coffee
you know i mean go to a place that
doesn't have donuts or something that
you know is your vice that you know you
shouldn't do
another thing you can be proactive when
i say avoiding temptation
if you want to really consistently make
the gym a part of your life set your
clothes out for the gym the night before
and it will remove the temptation
to not go to the gym when you wake up
you all of a sudden you have your
clothes there and you just hop in them
instead of looking all over the house i
can't find my shirt i can't find my
socks i don't know what's going on
you'll have your clothes there and there
will be no excuse for you not to go
avoiding temptation is a way of life by
doing one thing differently you can
avoid all kinds of temptation and it is
the key to your self-discipline make a
damn schedule and stick to it okay so
what's the rule with the schedule
it's not a bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong they say well i don't like to have
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
i have to do this then i have to do this
then i have to do this you know and then
i just go play video games because who
wants to do all these things that i have
to do it's like wrong
set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want
that's the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow if i was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day i could
have
practically speaking
what would it look like well then you
schedule that and obviously there's a
bit of responsibility that's going to go
along with that because if you have any
sense one of the things that you're
going to insist upon is that at the end
of the day you're not in worse shape
than you were that than at the beginning
of the day right because that's a stupid
day if you have a bunch of those in a
row you just dig you know you dig
yourself a hole and then you bury
yourself in it's like sorry that's just
not a good strategy it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20 of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are but even that you can you
can ask yourself okay well i've got
these responsibilities i have to
schedule the damn things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward and you can ask yourself that
just like you'd negotiate with someone
who is working for you it's like okay
you gotta work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
gonna do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you do an hour of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes i don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great you know and you you're useless
and horrible so you'll probably only hit
it with about 70 accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
percent the next week or 50 and a half
percent for god's sake or because
you're you're going to hit that position
where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward big
thing that makes a good day versus not a
good day is exposure to cold
really yeah like wim hof style you mean
it's not a good day if you're not
exposed to cold it's not as good a day
really it's not as
there's something about that
not only pushing yourself i do it early
in the morning and you can either do it
in the shower like start with a warm
shower start doing the wim hof breathing
which starts to hyper oxygenate the body
also has a lot of health benefits and
then turning that shower nozzle cold
and for how long
for about three minutes is what you want
to do all the way cold and if you have a
cold pool or cold bath you can do that
but it's two-fold one it's going to
reduce your chronic stress so
norepinephrine goes up adrenaline goes
up and it drops your cortisol so it
drops the baseline of stress that we all
carry all the time but the other thing
is it's that moment right before you
turn that nozzle where every part of you
is like nah not today yeah fear you're
like i don't want to do you don't want
to do that you turn it over
it's cold
exactly exactly
even though you know it's not going to
hurt you even though you know it's going
to benefit you it's going to develop
cold shock proteins it's going to help
your immune system you know people
exposed to cold get 43 less respiratory
infections like it's opposite really of
the wives tales that we've heard like
don't go out in the cold you'll you'll
get sick like regular mediated exposure
to cold is actually going to help your
immune system so even with all those
that's going to boost the immune system
the more you do it yeah so you believe
when we have the discipline to
put ourselves through controlled stress
for a few minutes it's going to give us
extreme benefits the rest of the day no
doubt because it's the same thing like
when we're thinking about whether we
want to work out or not right right
we're sitting around like yeah you know
i really should go out and take that run
i really should go out and take that
workout we know we're going to feel
better when we do it we know we're going
to be better but what is that part of
ourself that's going to
turn that little bit extra over to the
yes column you know it's something i
call mental override and i talk about it
in the book it's the ability to use your
mind
to give you that little extra to push
you into yes
mental override yeah and it's the same
thing that you would same thing that you
would use if you need to start that
project or if you're screwing around on
emails and need to actually get to the
meat of the problem at work it's that
same mental technique that's going to
allow you to kill it but you get to
practice that in the morning and you get
to have that small win so that the next
time you're facing that oh i really
should start that big project i really
should work on this you just have that
same attitude like all right i'm going
to do it yeah so i do uh scream to me
the other night hey will i want to be an
actor man i want to be an actor just
like you you know usually people say
stuff to me like that i'm like yeah man
you know you do it's giving an
encouraging word but i was just sitting
here thinking and it dawned on me
99
of people that say stuff like that are
not willing to do what it takes to make
their dreams come true the marines have
a saying everybody wants to go to heaven
but nobody wants to die
and that's just real at the center of
bringing any dream into fruition is
self-discipline you know some something
as simple as food and eating is not
about your your body as much as it is
about your mind it's getting command of
your mind to be able to choose actions
that are in your own best interest every
day
we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you and the
world's trying to hold you down so you
gonna kick yourself in the balls
so you don't stop yourself from getting
what you dream
self-discipline is the center of all
material success you cannot win the war
against the world if you can't win the
war against your own mind
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
need more discipline in your life check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there how could you be
productive have a vibrant life be
successful if someone else controls all
your time or you're filled with clutter
so i did a very simple thing
we can all do it